hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the moon okay we're
about to make our first memory hop
backwards in time as far as I know
release anything to prepare holy crap
that's a lot of data what am i doing
about this complete the momento flip
click the orb to flip pieces mouki handy
that oh I see what I need to do okay
this is actually simple hey I did it I
got the memento the memento can now be
activated for traversal I can already
tell this game is gonna blow my mind and
so many ways it's gonna have so much
interesting stuff to it hi I'm so
excited it's been a long time since I've
actually played a game that has like a
really truly interesting story wait what
about my privacy I don't want you to see
anything too dastardly we'll try not to
violate what we can avoid but in most
cases it can't be helped boo boo boo I'm
going to see all your dirty secrets oh
why did the the memory oh here it is
it's back again whoa that is oh yeah man
indeed the idea of just like going
through someone's entire life is a
pretty invasive thing seeing every
single memory that they have would be
nuts turn off visibility and
interactivity it'd be messy
to be seen yeah yeah happy oh there's
the platypus
started creepy and wanted cheerful Jase
what's with all these rabbits this is
creeping me out we probably should have
checked his record for psychopathy first
ooh what did he hear me
that's impossible it's probably just
part of its memory in the world
okay he's angry about something then I
stand by my point
anyway quit blabbering and fine a
momento here to hop from okey-dokey then
what's God why is the music so dramatic
what is happening in this game requires
memory links to shoot okay interact with
Anglais objects to establish five memory
lengths clapping is moving but soundless
okay so I got something from there so I
can't go down there can I go upstairs
and that guy's is standing at the piano
go hello he's up here now okay weird
Russia whoa what is happening glass
bottle of pickled olives hey hey this
stuff what's a pickled olive everything
exactly gross I like pickles but pickled
anything else an old and patched up
backpack but as this a million years old
I guess we'll find out all right plenty
of memories
the Emperor's New Clothes hey I read
something that's a good book selection
of readings for medical journals can't
go down there come on come along now
sometimes it interacts with things that
I'm not nearby and clicking on fresh
wildflowers don't we have to explain our
presence to him at every memory I'd go
crazy
don't tell me can now travel with the
memento the umbrella okay so the
umbrella the umbrella was like the
central link to all these and then I was
finding supplemental memories that
allowed me to go backwards in time was
with this rabbit anyway was it here
multi colored paper rabbit is this is
gonna be like a clue a breadcrumb
throughout the entire series well aren't
you special having two colors when all
your siblings look like they drown in
Bleach what's that
you think you're really creepy why yes
hey Bray ah see anyway cuz we're done
here it is really creepy why is it
creepy supposed to be a beautiful story
caboose caboose key I'm literally
shooting in the minute it did be hot
doggin nice very good you're full of
sick references what the heck was that
what that's it I'm doing the breaking
from now on he has no respect this dr.
Watts has no respect
okay prepare let's do this I'm gonna
keep jumping back in time under this
guy's memories Oh reminder the corner of
orb can flip an entire diagonal well
that's handy I'll definitely use that to
the best of my ability or something or
other no blue blue blue blue blue blue
blue
okay so it's probably supposed to go in
a sequence or something I don't remember
though who knows huh but okay so now I
should be able to flip this flip this
flip this okay got it got it got it okay
my brain is working in Maximum Overdrive
probably because I've commandeered the
brain of an old man to be able to do
more oh wait
activate I don't think there was
anything else I was here supposed to see
there's a creepy old man sitting as
piano staring as
we got the blood as was with him that's
not creepy not that creepy anyway when
it comes to rain through is better than
on - I don't mind it regardless I
actually like the rain - seems like
these memory Hobbs only Spanish ort
period of time we need to find a leaping
memento or it's going to take forever
man just enjoy the scenery okey-dokey
then
in memory of river e Wiles that must
have been his wife Nami are you a rain
person I don't find many people that
actually like rain and gloomy days
requires three bars of memory links to
proceed like I really thoroughly enjoy
like whenever it's cloudy and overcast
because those are the days really like I
really enjoyed looking out and like
makes me smile something I don't get
here in LA wait how do I get memory
links I can't go anywhere else so
something else I'm supposed to look at
huh
okey-dokey then what am I supposed to do
where am I supposed to go hello hello
anybody
I can't move anywhere I move so slowly I
supposed to go well I'm lost already
it shouldn't be too surprising something
I miss in my notes or my items - I
platypus I have the paper rabbit and I
have the platypus and I also have the
patient monitor so I'll be able to see
because he should save quite frequently
but what am I supposed to do how am I
supposed to do this there's no memory
links to be had there's nothing else
here oh there we go and old stall okay
honestly I just don't think this animal
has the right to exist the world's not
big enough for the two of you I thought
I was already clicked on the guy
I didn't realize there's a whole bunch
of other stuff to be clicked on that
might be near near and dear to things
okay it's finished River
what's finished
like you I'll be able to watch over her
every day she won't be alone anymore
I might never understand why but I
stayed true to your wish I'm sure Anya
is grateful to you too but when I'm gone
who's gonna watch over us
Oh
who are you my name is Eva I was just
passing by but she was she your wife yes
her name was River that's a special name
it didn't need to happen hmm she she
didn't need to do it
she
you wouldn't understand I don't even
understand
oh man there's gonna be some game it's
been so long since I played a game with
actual good storytelling developing
characters like introducing characters
making you care about characters note
about Anya damn someone John and River
cared for who is Anya was Anya the
caretaker is the caretaker like their
daughter that's what he was saying while
he was he gonna be able to watch over
them watch over her specifically I think
is what she said so that must mean that
there's something about that about time
you got here I almost thought you fell
off the cliff what were you doing
enjoying the scenery what else any luck
here
big luck huge dinosaur ik huh this place
looks pretty empty it's a lighthouse
what do you expect anyway I'll catch you
on the other side have fun reap breaking
the barrier for yourself oh thanks dick
okay oh great oh I need more mementos I
don't have enough what a douchebag watts
uh uh alright so I got to go back down I
got to find another memory I guess I'm
on autopilot we I was on autopilot hey
dude I need more orbs and they'll am I
gonna get awards I couldn't move
anywhere around here so there must have
been something up there that I didn't
need I think anyway unless the
lighthouse itself is like an object who
knows good god what is going on in the
story it's so weird and interesting
there we go that's what I thought whoa
hi there alright you didn't look at me
a little weird okay got all the
technology you lose sittin in the
lighthouse being creepy being sad
actually alright prepare it time for a
puzzle
flip the do see ideal shows the minimum
number of moves Mentos can be complete
early I think I see it hubba-hubba the
boom guy I did it I did it ideally does
I mean is gonna be better for moving
through time or what I have no idea
here we go we huh
he's so sad that platypus oh good we
went a little bit farther back in time
which is barely Oh No
just enough
after we pay for your operation we'll
have just enough left for it so don't
you worry white lie that's what you call
it right no I'm sure we can just stop it
I don't like it when you lie
I calculated our finances I know it's
like why do you try to convince me
against my will
we need the money for your medical bills
River I understand that Anja means a lot
to you but this this is just too much I
mean she she isn't even do you know what
makes me happy Johnny what do you well I
do I just hope you can help me with it
River when the papers from my treatments
get here I will not sign them what you
do with our money is up to you but if
you would grant my wish I want you to
use it to finish building that house and
then for every day that you live there I
want you to watch over her visitor speak
to her comforter I don't want it to be
alone anymore and what about you
happy I'll be happy
Johnny yes
I made this
tell me what it is what just tell me
what it is it's a rabbit I call the
others you made what else
um it's made of paper what else
it's bodies yellow and the rest is blue
good what else
look River I wrote a song it's for you
okay
well would you like to hear it
yes you didn't have to bring the piano
in here for this I can hear you this
fine with the door open
it's called for river that was a song in
the beginning of the game
why so cliche it's just a placeholder
who is this Anya they were talking about
if she's so important shouldn't we have
seen her in his late memories I guess he
didn't keep that promise after all
unless unless what
nevermind hey that's the same song the
kids were playing earlier huh
I guess he taught them
you know what I'm too manly for this I'm
heading on
I already got my memory links you want
to hitch her a quick ride or look around
for yourself I'm gonna say an explorer
go on and I'll catch up with you don't
you miss the days when memory audio to
mp8 conversion was illegal was legal I
think I brought home over 2000 songs
during my first year on this job yeah
cuz this is one you'd wanna rip good job
that guy's prick
receives note paper rabbit okay note
says paper rabbit what River gave to
John so these notes are gonna be
important the emperor's new clothes hey
is that book again this is important
because there was some lesson in there
to be learned about how the kid only saw
something that no one else could see
such a pretty soundtrack - it's so
pretty
god it's pretty a pot of mixed dough
glass of pickled olives
someone really likes these hello
I'm telling you there's just no way what
if we take it apart look at us John we
aren't exactly at the ripe age of piano
moving you know what if this means that
much to you I'll pay for the
professionals to do this I can't help
saving that house for you so this is the
least I can do so he adds someone moved
the piano just so his wife could hear it
hear the song that he wrote God so sad -
okay wait there was something down there
or was that just like a wait symbol I
think I might just a bit wait symbol I
just take one more look cuz yeah yeah
that was all what yes it's a wait symbol
sorry it's catching me off guard because
I see it change and I think there might
be something thing I still don't know if
you guys can see it sorry I may I
totally forgot I was so engrossed in
getting to play this again that I forgot
that I might need to turn on the mouse
cursor I don't know how important it is
so we'll see we'll see because I only
recorded this one in the last one in a
row so I'm gonna be able to read the
comments after this one so you guys can
tell me what you're thinking and if
you'd rather see what I'm about to click
on so the ideal is for huh okay
this is gonna be a pain in the butt oh
boy
damnit
damnit I did that way over ID love for I
got into nine poopy poopy honor if
that's gonna count against me towards
the end of the game I need to be better
at buzz goals why am I so bad all right
where are we now God we are not moving
back very quickly I'll tell you that V
again maybe the whole game is just going
back in time trying to find out more
about this guy's life
finally finally what your big goof your
big dumb goof okay what's that whoa okay
then whoop-dee-doo all right so what are
we looking for now look what we have
here all the house hasn't been built yet
oh okay
interesting so he was building the house
before River got sick I bet they saw
this cliff and thought that it was not
dangerous enough without people living
on it all right you're very clever very
clever Oh what's the that guy I mean
that's obviously the guy but what's with
him
Nick called and said I should come here
I brought you pickled olives they're
your favorite right I heard about river
will she be okay
her illness was just diagnosed in its
late stage fortunately it's treatable
with the medical bills
we can't afford to finish building this
house Isabelle you can barely afford to
pay for a treatment I'm just relieves it
she'll be okay but you don't know how
much this place means to her she's going
to be heartbroken I'd help but ten and I
barely Evan have been barely getting by
since the market crashed what are you
going to do now I'm going to tell her
that we can make it I'm gonna tell her
that we can afford everything I don't
want her to do anything crazy you
shouldn't lie to her
you don't understand Isabel if she found
out I'm not sure which she'd choose so
what if she chooses not to save herself
for the sake of this place then so be it
it's what she really wants I've really
disliked when you neurotypical typicals
think you know what's best for others
hey when you call me that is he do you
think this is all about her
what about me Isabelle after all these
years am I not allowed to be selfish
even once I don't want to be alone
Isabelle I'm not going to let her die
that's arrogant I don't care
where are you going I'm going to pick
something from this cliff to bring her
back to her it'll at least give her some
comfort that doesn't make what you're
doing any less wrong Nick wanted me to
give you this
he said it's called
everything's all right it isn't
story is so sad and intricate since the
sad chapters of this guy's life all
unfolding yeah we gotta hunt some more
memories more mementos oh we got here
got that is that important over there no
how about on the side of the house can't
get in there but I've been inside the
house what about that lady about that
box
the music box no whatever it's just so
sad but it's so good to see something
like this happen not not the misery of
what's happening his life with the fact
that this game actually has heart and
character and actually makes the
characters like fleshed out even though
they're 2d models they're just sprites
with text boxes like they have
characters like reading a book a really
good book that won't ever enough falling
over let's see what the actual thing it
wants for me is it's like a guided
adventure to a novel so cool anyway I
mean I actually know that I like it cuz
I'm actually getting wrapped up in it
okay why did that trigger something
there though is there something there
for me to see so the lighthouse was
already there before they built the
house they either own the land or they
bought it just to build it by the
lighthouse I don't know why either way
let's shoot this globule with my memory
bubbles yep yep it's an awfully weird
system your technology has developed oh
yeah let's see if I cannot be as dumb
this time and actually do this Capri
Utley Capri Utley okay this needs two
flips a flip flip flip flip okay full of
love you and then
oh I got it okay I can do this oh
I'm still over I thought I had that oh
well you pickled olives gross
now two pickled olives activates haha I
really don't know how I could have done
that better but I failed anyway so
that's all that matters okay we're
almost approaching late adulthood
not quite they're still old and gray at
least River isn't sick yet maybe this is
gonna be as sad so you guys are really
going for it huh yeah my construction
starting in just a few months it's a bit
of a squeeze we had to split the payment
but with financing we'll make it do what
my dear well make it do
how wonderful having your dream house
built it's such a beautiful sight you
had your wedding at that lighthouse near
those near there all those years ago
didn't you
that's not all that special about it we
have a long history with that place well
it's good to have some good news and get
together for once
cheers and congratulations you two Hey
Cheers be right back I'm gonna get some
fresh air
me too
well buddy sure been a while hasn't it
know how hard it is to get across a few
cities nowadays that River still so
quiet huh yeah she's actually been
talkative at home and with Isabel I
guess she's just not used to you yeah so
on the bad guy here huh all right how
did you tell River that thing from back
then I did so how'd she take it for the
most part she took it well but something
bugs me things get creepy ever since the
incident she's been making these strange
rabbits out of paper origami rabbits yes
lots of them huh I used to fold origami
animals from my daughter all the time
what's wrong with that I don't think
it's the same thing she's been doing
nothing but making the same rabbits day
and out my house is literally filled
with him now didn't Isabelle say
something that like that is a common
trait with rivers condition yes but
something doesn't feel right this time
when I asked her about it she never
answers instead she gets this distant
look in her eyes it's almost as if
something she wants something from me
and the strange thing is I feel like
there's something I owe her to have you
asked his Abell yes she said she talked
to her about it but got nothing
things got really creepy all of a sudden
I don't know why well I'm certainly not
one to enquire but I'll tell you this
I've known you since middle school and
you're notorious for overthinking you're
probably just imagining things there's
no need to get too worked up usually
when someone says that something always
goes wrong something's always wrong but
I'll give you the benefit of the doubt
you're probably right
probably I'm always right John gotta
believe in me gotta believe in me
there's a weird voyeuristic sense to all
this like just observing this unraveling
wait so even he himself never knew what
was up with those rabbits forget about
the stupid rabbits we got bigger
problems
it's a confined memory and they're no
mementos here don't worry we can
probably draw one out from him
how leave it to me I just got to give
the bartender a quick visit first yeah
yeah hey could I get you anything
hey oh how could I get a bottle of
pickled olives please jerk ass credit
check here um I'm sorry we don't take
chickens oh I just put it on my tab then
wait I mean you don't have any money
oh you're so getting resetted hey there
can I get you anything
high-low can I get a bottle of biggle
olives please sure gosh you're at it Ted
put it on a DAB
I feel like spending big today oh thank
you sir
here's your pickled olives get my hop to
me thanks bro
you'll be getting enormous amount of
dips today thank you sir thank you your
birthday my life it says an ass Neil Oh
loosen up it's just a memory does that
all matter oh look man how much does
this guy love pickled olives why Santa
bottle of pickled olives you're sporting
yeah you a fellow olive lover
indeed I am just got a fresh bottle then
my selves in fact mind if I join you
Joe why don't you grab a seat well down
a bottle together oh yeah that sounds
just swell you disabled say simulation
now Oh Neil I don't think I feel like it
I'm so gonna get you back for this well
that's hell we got our first sister ah
you okay yes I'm just savoring the
amazingness of pickled olives they're
wonderful aren't they yes you can't
understand
anyone could find such things to be
disgusting take your time we got two
bottles left
yeah so I said hey that's all right and
they totally agreed how do you know what
else is wrong with society today
all right going our exam easy Isley have
it right here why Matt see it okay
you're a friendly shop here it is and
freeze okey-dokey then
what is with the pile of amorphous blob
next to him yeah finally
dear Lord how are the olives Neil oh
shut your mouth okay what do we got
whoa Zippy's Abbey my man Joe detected
seriously it looks like some pile of
goop sitting ISM don't worry geesh hey
Joe see I'm doing it by the books puppet
head hold okay Hulk smash oh this guy's
such a nerd and I love it Neil
seriously I'm trying to get into this
and you're ruining the mood totally
worth it okay before I do that before I
jump in again it is time to end this
episode here so I hope you guys are
enjoying this so far I am actually
thoroughly thoroughly enjoying this but
I want to know what you guys think in
the description below this is kind of a
long game I think it's like I looked up
the time to completion it was right 4 to
5 hours so it's gonna be a bit of a long
series so I want to know what you think
in the description below try to keep
this boiler free if you can there's
other people that probably haven't seen
the game yet but thank you again
everybody so much for watching check out
the other games that I played down the
description below that have heart and
soul to them and as always I will see
you in the next video bye
oh wait a minute what the hell go back
Crete 6 don't you put your soul to rest
that's not very good scolding you need
to really learn okay lady
let's get one thing straight this blue
it's ugly
that dress bow